We need to change the
conversation, period.
About the aspiration is
not to be a millionaire
it's to be,
[Music Playing]
[Cheering]
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you just want to be happy?
[Music playing]
- [AJ] I was just in Miami and Orlando.
I leave to Peru to do shows
because I also host parties.
- [Gary] God I love Peru.
[AJ Laughs]
- [AJ] After that I go to Puerto Rico
then I going to Venezuela,
then I'm going to Mexico
so it's like, but this
is my branding myself.
Because no one becomes a
millionaire nine to five, Gary.
And you say it all the time.
I'm hustling getting up at four o'clock
in the morning you know.
- [Gary] Honestly, I'm gonna take
this advantage, we need to
change the conversation, period.
About the aspiration is
not to be a millionaire,
it's to be happy
- [AJ] Amen.
- [Gary] For real. Like
you know how happy you are?
You imagine 16 year old you being like
I'm gonna go to Peru and
I'm gonna fucking visit
like get the fuck.
- [AJ] And I think the universe,
because for at one point in my life too
I had the money or everything was there
that I always wanted.
But then I took at step back.
- [Gary] You weren't happy.
- [AJ] I was not happy.
I left the number one
radio station in the world,
and I left it because I wasn't happy.
- My 2019 agenda is to make
happy, like for you to say,
and you're doing it subconsciously.
Not everyone is happy at 27.
If I can replace the word
millionaire with happy,
and I'm crazy I think I can pull it off.
- [AJ] What do you do Gary when,
lets say you're at a location,
you're at a point in your life that,
obviously you need to pay bills
but you're no longer happy.
What do you do?
- [Gary] You need to change your bills.
- [AJ] Okay, okay.
- [Gary] You need to not
buy a fresh fucking hoodie.
You may need to move in
to a shittier apartment.
- [AJ] Okay.
- [Gary] I'm being dead serious.
One of the other conversations I'm having
is change your bills.
If you're not happy, but you got bills.
Why don't you look at your bills?
Happiness.
- [AJ] Happiness is key.
- [Gary] No dude, it's everything.
[Music Playing]
There's not a lot of people
crying for pretty girls.
But you're sitting here, and
when you wake up in the morning
you're like fuck.
Instagram's the most important platform.
Right, and 91 percent
of my audience are dudes
that want to see my body.
I want to be known for music.
Every time I post music it
gets no fucking engagement.
Every time I post skin it gets engagement,
and nobodies crying for
pretty girl problems.
But the reality is its your problem.
- [Krystal] It's been frustrating for sure
because like a lot of people
are telling me well mix both,
the sexy and the music.
But I would like for people to listen.
- [Gary] Make a video straight
to face and be like yo dudes.
I know why you're here, I get it.
If you have gotten value out of me,
just put me on one time, right now.
Tag your sister, your mom,
your girlfriend, your wife,
because I'm about to
put out a lot of music,
and like I just want some of that love.
People want real.
Hey, fuck this transition
from model to musician
has been tough.
You mother fuckers don't
want to like my shit
because I don't give you tits and ass.
I'm fucking struggling
creatively and got nothing
to fucking give for you music wise.
Like who else is struggling today.
That's when you will pop.
If you're not full of shit,
which I really believe you're not.
Then put out the fucking music for a year,
and then fucking get frustrated
at the end of the year
that it didn't happen, and
then put out bikini shots.
But that will, you got time.
You're not 80 yet.
- [Krystal] Mhm
- [Gary] You can model next
year, do you know what I mean?
- [Krystal] Yeah I do.
- [Gary] So do it.
- [Krystal] Go on hard.
- [Gary] Otherwise you're
half fucking pregnant.
Half pregnant means you don't know.
You're like oh if I went all in.
That's what you're doing
when you're laying in bed.
If I went all into
music, what would happen?
- [Krystal] Glean, have you heard of that?
Because another kind of
route I was going to take
during my rollout to get people engaged.
And you know, keep people listening
and pretty much kind of like a sweepstakes
type of tracker thing.
- [Gary] Listen. Listen to me face.
- [Krystal] Listen to my face?
- [Gary] Please, really listen to me.
You're looking for shortcuts.
Your body's a shortcut.
Gleam's a shortcut.
Sweepstakes are a shortcut.
Contests are a shortcut.
Put out fucking music.
- [Krystal] Okay.
[Krystal Laughs]
- [Gary] Here's why.
You're young enough to do it
all in for a period of time
and then decide.
- [Krystal] Right.
- [Gary] You know what I'm saying?
You're blessed with options.
- [Krystal] Yes.
- [Gary] Right.
- [Krystal] Mhhm.
- [Gary] You agreed
right? You felt that one.
- Yes I did.
- [Gary] You're blessed with options.
Whoa is me, you have
to settle in two years
to back to modeling.
- [Krystal] I'm never going back.
- [Gary] Well fine, so if
you're never going back.
So if you're not going back
then don't be half assed.
- [Krystal] Okay.
All music.
- [Gary] All music.
- [Krystal] Everyday.
- [Gary] Everyday.
Hey everybody this is the
ask Gary Vee show and we,
- [Mark] No, no, no. This is my show.
So today we're going to be
pairing wine with three foods.
And by that I mean we're
going to be pairing cat wine,
wine made made specifically
for cats with three different
food flavor candy canes.
- [Gary] Let's go.
- [Mark] Cheers.
- [Gary] Cheers to good health.
That is atrocious.
- [Mark] Well by paring it with
mac and cheese candy canes,
that really tastes like
mac and cheese doesn't it?
- [Gary] Delicious.
Are those oyster flavored?
- [Mark] We'll get to that Gary.
What is the largest mammal
you think you can knock out
with a single punch?
- [Gary] A pony?
- [Mark] A pony?
[Laughing]
We have some rotisserie
chicken candy cane.
- [Gary] Wow this smells atrocious.
Tastes exactly like it.
- [Mark] Alright how does
this pair with your wine?
- [Gary] Terrible.
- [Mark] It's kind of like
a Thanksgiving at my house.
- [Gary] This is delicious.
- [Mark] Oh no.
- [Mark] Don't like this one. Oh man.
- [Gary] This is tough. I love it.
- [Mark] If you could
buy the Jetts right now.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Mark] With the one stipulation that
you had to wear Jordan every single day
for the rest of your
life, would you do it?
- [Gary] Not yet.
- [Mark] Really?
- [Gary] Really. I'd wait.
- [Mark] Any final,
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Mark] words that you wanna,
- [Gary] Almost everybody
who's going to watch this
is unfortunately living their lives
based on somebody else's opinions.
And that leads to
extraordinary unhappiness.
And we need to start making a
millionaire not the ambition,
but being a happy person the ambition.
And I really believe
that's about to happen.
And I want to be one of
the people that drives that
conversation amongst the hundred
thousands of other people
that need to do it for it
to actually become real.
But boy do in want to eliminate judgment.
Everyone here is judging people.
We judge so much.
And now with the way
modern technology works
its so easy to judge at
scale with so little context.
So a little less judgment
and a little more empathy.
Hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on youtube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I am working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all.
Please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether its a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of wine a year.
Or giveaway 36 bottle of wine a year.
Please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.
[Music playing]